nouns that a sequel to Dishonored was in
development marking a new chapter to the
game of the year from Arkane Studios we
shared a few tidbits about the sequel
but for the most part you could say
we've been in stealth mode until now
sorry I couldn't help myself
Dishonored 2 is going to be a very
special game one that lives up to the
celebrated legacy and then goes way
beyond to tell you more please join me
in welcoming the creative director of
dishonour to Harvey Smith
Wow thanks Pete hi everybody in
Dishonored you play a supernatural
assassin in a steampunk City the game
blends combat stealth and mobility
giving you many different pathways and
approaches when the original dishonored
was released in 2012 you embraced the
game and made it your own
you discovered moves and combinations of
powers that we didn't even imagine we
were thrilled by your passion for
Dishonored and we were humbled by the
success of the game which won more than
100 Game of the Year awards at last
year's e3 we announced Dishonored 2 so
tonight here with all of you for the
first time we're going to show you the
game
welcome back to the Empire of the Isles
a rich Victorian inspired fantasy world
with a distinct style and an exotic cast
of characters
for Dishonored - we wanted to explore a
new location car naka the jewel of the
south our approach to world creation is
very layered our art and design teams
work together to create a strong sense
of place with a well realized culture
it's based on the people living there
the work they do the architecture
economy the climate even the food and
songs
in order to bring car naca to life we've
created a custom game engine designed to
support our signature art direction and
level design we wanted Dishonored 2 to
resemble a painting in motion so we've
given considerable thought Sora lighting
and the way it plays across every
surface we've created custom tools to
support the interrupt abow real-time
narrative scenes necessary for a stealth
simulation and the same is true for our
approach to audio both in terms of
atmospherics and stealth gameplay all of
these details make Carnac a more vivid
thanks to our new technology which we
call the void engine
in crafting spaces for you to explore
we've got several creative goals we want
the environment to feel coherent and
complete plausible where do these
characters live and how do they get to
work is there a viable pathway that
makes sense
where do they take their breaks or stop
for lunch but it goes further than that
for dishonor - we felt compelled to ask
ourselves about the history of a given
street or shop what was there a decade
before the player arrives in karnataka
often you can see the layers of history
watermarks on the wall from past floods
peeling posters and advertisements from
years ago we want every market every
alley to tell a story and offer you the
chance to see something novel or
intriguing
dishonor two starts and ends in dunwall
but most of the action takes place here
in Karnataka
all right there you go your first look
at dishonor - thank you on behalf of all
my teammates at arcane and Leon who
worked so hard to bring this to you on
my dear friend raphaël colantonio thank
you so much for all the passion you've
given the game in the first dishonor
game you played Corvo attano falsely
accused of killing the Empress the woman
he loved and was sworn to protect and
you were blamed for the abduction of
their daughter emily kaldwin after
escaping on the night of his execution
Corvo is gifted with supernatural powers
and dedicates himself to avenging the
death of the Empress and restoring young
Emily to the throne as we begin to work
on Dishonored to a single question
haunted us what became of emily kaldwin
how would her experiences affect her and
what kind of ruler would she become we
envisioned Emily grown up 25 years of
age and then we begin to imagine what
she'd be like as a heroic figure as
someone fighting for her life against
the forces of deceit we developed a
vision for emily kaldwin that excited us
and at e3 last year we shared that
vision with the world Dishonored 2 set
15 years after the first game emily
kaldwin rules the Empire watched over by
her father
Corvo attano
all hail her Imperial Majesty emily
kaldwin loyal subjects were going
through a difficult time but today we
honor my mother the late Jessamine
cauldron may her memory survive through
the ages
number one retired father every year I
think the anniversary of Justinian's
death will be easier it never is
I wish your mother will still be
impressed I'm very good at this you're
still learning don't worry about the
rabble rousers and we'll catch the crown
killer eventually people are saying to
you hope these assassinations are a
misguided effort to protect me no
someone's trying to make us look guilty
by targeting your enemies I wish I could
just run away from all this sometimes
you do you think I don't know about your
nights out on the rooftops courage the
ceremony will be over soon royal
protector and father we should have
passed a law against that combination
tiles years ago
when an otherworldly usurper seizes the
throne the fate of the Empire is left
hanging in the balance Dishonored 2
offers you the choice of playing as
empress emily kaldwin or the royal
protector Corvo attano emily in Corvo
are both fully voiced this time with
their own perspectives and emotional
responses to the events transpiring
around them whether you choose to play
whoever you choose to play you've got to
flee down while you're home and travel
to karnataka in order to unravel the
threads of a conspiracy and take back
what's yours
I should talk to the captain of that
ship
dishonored is known for unscripted
simulation driven missions where no two
players ever have the same experience
there are many pathways to explore as
you penetrate well-defended locations
many numerous ways to find and eliminate
nefarious targets in crafting the
missions for Dishonored - we've put a
much greater emphasis on big interesting
themes either from a gameplay or
fictional standpoint making each mission
a wildly unique place to explore I'll
explain a little bit more about that
today we're going to show you the dust
district an industrial ruin ravaged by
terrible storms that hit at random
intervals in the dust district a
militant religious faction called the
overseers is at war with the howler gang
the leaders of both factions are trying
to take each other down you can side
with the overseers or the howlers or
neither there are many ways to complete
the mission to tell you more I'll wait
skip take you back to the dreadful wail
after the fish
everything you see here is rendered in
the void engine designed to create
atmospheric and exploration rich spaces
to reach our target vice overseer burn
we've got to get past a grand guard
checkpoint sealed off by a wall of light
a cruel security device reinstated by
the Duke of Sir Kono's board is from the
Duke what did you do me good soldiers
blinded by that pollution of genic power
to the howl is used then stabbed to
death or dragged down by the abc1 yo and
it got hit by it oversee it Renee
[ __ ] let's hope they do enough damage to
each other so the fight goes out of him
can I won't happen until someone manages
to kill your Paulo or buy servers we've
made much greater use of vertical space
for this honor - encouraging players to
explore the rooftops above the street
instead of my ears
mm-hmm
with storm alters visibility for the AI
and for the player a random storm hits
and Emily comments on it many of the
security devices in Dishonored 2 are
powered by wind a unique feature of
Karnataka so here we're switching off
the windmill to get through the wall of
light there'll be a lot going on in this
next fight drop attack guards climbing
and vaulting combat choke and Emily
using far reach to pull an explosive
whale oil tank toward her from a
distance
you are going okay
you
all right let's jump forward closer to
our target by silver sear burn the
overseers are fighting the howler gang
for the hearts and minds of the people
of Karnataka what happens here will
influence Karnataka's future and the end
games with me he's upstairs now
so I see we'll learn something but all
along here we're gonna use Emily's
mesmerize power to lull a group of
overseers into a stupor evading combat
altogether
mesmerize they won't notice Emily or
even note remember that she was here I
feel so empty right now
far reach can be upgraded not only to
pull objects from the distance but also
enemies so you can finish them off in
midair this time all of Emily's powers
which are new and all of corvo's can be
fully upgraded using entirely new skill
trees giving you the ability to
customize more deeply if you're new to
the dishonored series it's all about
options and exploration playing at your
own pace the game has many different
pathways through each mission and also
different approaches stealth or combat
lethal or non-lethal and a wider range
of a wide array of supernatural powers
that will dramatically change the
experience as you play we're very close
to Vice overseer burns office now
the systems of inter ocular what I've
seen it and I feel it in my bones
so this stalemate with the howlers must
be with all burners giving a briefing
using a projector we're going to plant a
stun mine and then link several of the
overseers with Emily's Domino power so
that whatever happens to one of them
will happen to all of them they share
the same fate about the next day to find
him switching off the projector will
attract vice overseer Byrnes attention
and when the mine affects one overseer
it will affect all of them go check
brother right
there are many creative ways to use
Domino now we're gonna show you shadow
walk another key power for Emily
shadow walk is useful for stealth and
combat you saw it in the announced
trailer that we made for the game and
you can fully use it in the game like
all the powers that can be upgraded in a
variety of ways with Vice overseer
burnout of the picture the leader of the
howlers willow Emily a favor and that's
just one way to complete the dust
district mission before closing today we
want to demonstrate another signature
environment from a mission called a
crack in the slab it's another example
of the missions in Dishonored 2 and how
they're built around big interesting
themes this mission takes place in a
ruined Manor that's been sealed for
several years at the start the outsider
appears and explains that reality was
warped inside this place after an occult
event your supernatural powers won't
work inside the manor and even time
behaves strangely allowing you to travel
back and forth between the ruin present
and the past when the manor was lavish
and refined
here we're in the present when the manor
is in ruins
now we've moved backwards years into the
past when the manor was still inhabited
and guarded
looking through the lenses of the
outsider's timepiece you can see the
alternate timeline this is useful for
solving puzzles as you've seen but it
can also be used to avoid or take down
enemies you can watch enemies in the
alternate timeline and then step through
to execute your plans
we hope you're gonna love the game as
much as we do thank you thank you
laughter once again give a shout-out to
my team in France that worked so hard
and they are so passionate about the
game and the first game there they're
really ready for you to get it got you
guys to get your hands on it and you
don't have to wait long all of you can
leave your mark on the Empire of the
aisles because dishonored to release on
PlayStation for the Xbox one and PC
November 11 2016 but before I go I've
got one more thing for you this is the
worldwide launch of the Dishonored 2
gameplay trailer you're seeing it here
first
goodnight
all does
tegus and spoke
see you soon
sticker
clean for those who
ah
very excited about this honor - can I
please have another round of applause
for the very shy and took off Harvey
Smith